[Music]
imagine there's a mountain in front of
you that you need to climb the ground is
covered with stones and sharp rocks
above you can see snow but you're
barefoot and the only shoes you have are
a pair of stilettos that are three sizes
too small what would you do would you
crawl or someone to carry you just give
up that's what it's like to use a
wheelchair that hasn't been customized
for your body your environment and your
lifestyle and that's what life is like
for 52 million people every day but it
doesn't need to be we're going to look
at how we can disrupt resumption disrupt
my new factor and disrupt perceptions of
wheelchairs and the people who use them
so that's the trap assumptions I'm going
to start with a quick show of hands how
many of you have ever been backpacking
ok this is very impressive it's pretty
much the entire room and how many of you
have ever bought a Lonely Planet Travel
Guide that's actually way more
impressive that is pretty much everyone
- ok so that happens to me my go-to
guide and the first one I ever bought it
was for a sabbatical from work that I
found to spend backpacking around
Southeast Asia I started with a guide to
Thailand and there was temples there
were elephant sanctuary I couldn't have
been more excited so I planned my
itinerary and I put my ticket well it
was only then that I stumbled across a
chapter hidden at the back the
accessibility section so the advice was
unequivocal Thailand was not a suitable
destination for a disabled traveler I
might find wheelchair access in some of
the biggest hotels in larger cities
and that's when some of the major
resorts but other than that it was no-go
but when I started to think about it
it just didn't make any sense because
according to the World Health
Organization 1% of the population needs
to use a wheelchair so by my
calculations in the countries I plan to
visit there should be one wheelchair
user so every 99 people I saw walking
and if they could find a way to get
around then I could too
surely so I ignored the advice and I got
on the plane it was awesome and
accessible in its own way I strap my
wheelchair for the top of buses the back
of motorbikes I climb mountains on
donkeys I cross rivers on kayaks and
surprisingly one of the most remote
places I ever visited turned out to be
one of the most accessible a small rural
village in northern Laos had track
instead of road so they widened if I'd
walked me to have to navigate all the
houses we'll just built on a single
floor so there weren't any steps for me
to have to climb and the more I traveled
the more it started to occur to me that
often the places with the least
infrastructure were actually the easiest
for me to get around but there was
something really strange in two months
of traveling I only saw two other
wheelchair users and neither of them
were wheeling themselves they were both
being pushed in big heavy clunky
Hospital wheelchairs but you could never
will yourself in so I started to
investigate the people and organisations
that I met explained but to give
independence a wheelchair needs to be
customized to the body the lifestyle and
the environment of its users with
traditional manufacturing techniques the
cost of this is prohibitive a fully
customized wheelchair like mine cost
about $3,000
whether the country like Laos that fix
planes the average annual salary it's
just not affordable and according to the
World Health Organization worldwide
there are 52 million people who need a
wheelchair but can't afford one that
meets their needs the author just about
disrupting assumptions we needed to
disrupt manufacture I struggled with the
problem for months then in December 2015
I happen to visit an organization in
Jordan they were using 3d printing to
support refugees from the Syrian crisis
they showed me a fully customized
prosthetic hand that they made for a boy
who justice thinkers in the conflict
my first question how much did it cost
$39 they said impossible they explained
that 3d printing and digital fabrication
or ways to make customized products
products more cheaply still I wasn't
convinced what about the design cough
well there weren't any they used an open
source design freely available for
anyone anywhere to access adapter news
all they'd had to do enter the boys are
measurements and Press print seeing the
potential they all saw that anyone was
doing anything similar with wheelchairs
and their answer was simple no I was
blown away
why flew back to Europe and myself to
organize hackathons bringing together
wheelchair users designers makers
engineers artists students anyone who
was interested during our first
hackathon we stand one of the
participants back and but since the
information through to a CNC mill just
like you sent a document to a printer
and we milled the exact contours of his
body out of a piece of high-density foam
to create a highly personalized seat
background we also designed a
lightweight wheelchair frame using
off-the-shelf pieces of carbon fiber
that we cut to the exact youth leg
lengths of the user and join together
with loves that we 3d printed to match
the exact angle of their preferred
sitting position total cost $300 well we
had more hackathon we put our designs
online and our community started to grow
currently students from 84 universities
across the world are competing to design
a modular system the wheelchair parts
can be designed by different people made
in different places but still fit
together at the start our focus was just
on affordability but we learned
something else from the hackathons
even when people can afford $3,000 for a
fully customized wheelchair they still
won't Rafi because $3,000 wise the
ability to customize for function but
not for forms it wasn't just about the
throttling manufacturer we needed a way
to disrupt the sepsis
so I was eight-years-old
lying on the optometrist black leather
couch after reading the last lines of
tiny little letters mr. Robinson got up
off his chair and he looked over me
saying Rachel you need to wear glasses
when I jumped off the chair I ran into
the store and I started trying on frame
after frame after frame
I was animated and I have never felt
more glamorous than I did back then aged
eight years old admiring my reflection
with my brand-new hot pink plastic
glasses ten years later I was also lying
down this time it was a hospital bed
this time was different again a doctor
got up and he leaned over me this time
he paused before saying Rachel your
you need to use a wheelchair but this
time there were no choice a trained
physiotherapist ordered my wheelchair
and the first time I saw myself sitting
in it I didn't recognize myself but our
glasses and wheelchairs really so
different it's not just perceptions of
how I look it's also perceptions of who
I am I'm going to let you into a little
secret people often tell me I am
inspirational because I use a wheelchair
that I backpack around the world I use a
wheelchair yet I have a job I use a
wheelchair yet I Drive a car but back
when I was just a glasses wearer no one
ever told me I inspire them but why
can't we view people who wear their
wheel like people who are glasses
we've looked at how we can disrupt the
functions how we can disrupt manufacture
and how we can disrupt perceptions the
wheelchairs and the people who use them
let's disrupt disability imagine there's
a mountain in front of you that you need
to climb the ground is covered with
stones and sharp rocks above you can see
snow up this time you put on your hiking
boots or maybe your wheels and what do
you do you climb
[Applause]
you
[Music]